[موسيقى]
حضور متواضع في الشرق الاوسط وتركيز اكبر
على المخاطر القادمه من الصين وروسيا في
هذا السياق تاتيه خطه الولايات المتحده
الراميه الى نقل مقاتلات حديثه من الشرق
الاوسط الى منطقتي اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
واوروبا واستبدالها بطائرات اي 10
الهجوميه القديمه
بحسب مسؤولين امريكيين فان الخطوه المقرره
تنفيذها في ابريل المقبل هي جزء من خطه
اوسع تنص على الاحتفاظ بقوات بحريه وبريه
متواضعه في الشرق الاوسط بينما ياتي نقل
المقاتلات الاكثر تطورا الى اوروبا واسيا
ضمن جهود واشنطن لردع بيجين وموسكو فالصين
في عرف البنتاجون هي الخطر الاكبر حاليا
بينما يتواصل القلق من تداعيات الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
هي طائره هجوم امريكيه دشنت في سبعينيات
القرن الماضي متخصصه في الاسناد القتالي
وتستخدم في تدمير الدبابات وغيرها من
المركبات المدرعه سلاحها الاساسيين مدفع
جاتلينج وهو عباره عن رشاش دوار ثقيل يطلق
اربعه الاف طلقه في الدقيقه كما يمكنها
استخدام ذخائر عاليه الدقه واسلحه موجهه
بالليزر مغلفه بدرع من التيتانيوم لحمايه
الطيار وهي قادره على الاستمرار بالطيران
حتى لو فقدت احد اجنحتها يبلغ طول الطائره
نحو 16 مترا وربع المتر وارتفاعها نحو
اربعه امتار ونصف ويزيد وزنها على 22 طنا
اما سرعتها القصوى فتصل لنحو 830 كيلومترا
في الساعه لكن رغم انها تعد اليوم بطيئه
وضعيفه وغير قادره على التعامل مع قدرات
الجيش الصيني المتناميه فان الخبراء
الامريكيين يرون انه لا يزال لديها فائده
في الشرق الاوسط
لاستخدامها ضد الميليشيات المسلحه باسلحه
خفيفه وهذا سيمكن البنتاجون من نقل
المقاتلات الحديثه متعدده المهام الى
المحيط الهادئ واوروبا
[موسيقى]